>>> TONIGHT 7.2 MILLION YMPIC
SIZE SWIMMING POOLS FULL OF
WATER.
THAT IS HOW MUCH ICE MELTED IN
GREENLAND IN JUST THREE DAYS
THIS WEEK DURING THE
UNPRECEDENTED GLOBAL HEAT WAVE.
ENOUGH TO COVER THE ENTIRE STATE
OF WEST VIRGINIA WITH A FOOT OF
WATER.
RENE MARSH IS "OUT FRONT" IN
GREENLAND.
>> Reporter: OFF THE COAST OF
NORTHWEST GREENLAND, THE WATER
IS PERFECTLY STILL, BUT PUDDLING
ON ICEBERGS INDICATE A
TRANSFORMATION IS UNDERWAY.
THAT'S THE SOUND OF RAPID
MELTING TRIGGERED BY A FEW DAYS
OF UNUSUALLY WARM TEMPERATURES.
DURING CNN'S FIRST THREE DAYS IN
NORTHERN GREENLAND, THE
TEMPERATURE TOPPED OUT NEARLY 10
DEGREES HIGHER THAN NORMAL.
IT'S DAYS LIKE TODAY, WARM
ENOUGH TO WEAR SHORT SLEEVES,
NEAR 60 DEGREES IN GREENLAND.
IT'S A HIGH MELT DAY WHEN IT'S
THIS UNUSUALLY WARM AND IT'S
ALSO DEEPLY CONCERNING FOR
SCIENTISTS.
>> IT DEFINITELY WORRIES ME.
WE ARE AT 67 LATITUDE ON TOP OF
THE WORLD AND WE COULD JUST
YESTERDAY FISH, NOT TODAY BUT
YESTERDAY WE COULD WANDER AROUND
IN OUR T-SHIRTS.
THAT WAS NOT EXPECTED.
>> IT'S AT THE MELTING POINT
TODAY.
>> Reporter: AT A RESEARCH SITE
IN NORTHEAST GREENLAND NEAR MELT
CONDITIONS AT AN ELEVATION OF
NEARLY 9,000 FEET MADE WHAT'S
USUALLY A FROZEN LANDING STRIP
INOPERABLE.
>> WE HAVE A PROBLEM WHEN IT'S
THIS SOFT AS THE SURFACE IS NOW.
>> Reporter: CLIMATE SCIENTISTS
TWEETED MINI HEAT WAVE, NEGATIVE
1.6 DEGREES CELSIUS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE GREENLAND ICE
SHEET.
OUR PLANNED PLANE IS POSTPONED.
THEY PASS THE TIME PLAYING
VOLLEYBALL IN SHORTS ATOP THE
ICE SHEET.
GLOBAL WARMING, TEMPERATURES
NEAR 32 DEGREES AT THIS ALTITUDE
WERE UNHEARD OF.
THE NATIONAL SNOW AND ICE CENTER
SAYS FROM JULY 13th THROUGH 17th
A MELT SURGE CAUSED ICE SHEET
RUNOFF OF 6.7 TONS OF WATER PER
DAY.
THAT'S THE VOLUME OF 2.4 MILLION
OLYMPIC SIZED POOLS.
PUT ANOTHER WAY, ENOUGH WATER TO
FLOOD THE ENTIRE STATE OF WEST
VIRGINIA WITH ONE FOOT OF WATER
IN THREE DAYS.
>> THE AMOUNT OF MELT FROM THE
ICE WAS -- TO US WAS VERY
SURPRISING BECAUSE IT WAS VERY
WARM AIR.
YOU WOULD HEAR THE ICE JUST
MELTING IN FRONT OF US.
>> Reporter: RESEARCH SCIENTISTS
TELL CNN THIS EXTENT OF MELT IN
NORTH GREENLAND THIS LAST WEEK
IS QUITE UNUSUAL AND WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO GLOBAL SEA LEVEL
RISE WHICH IMPACTS COASTAL
COMMUNITIES HALF A WORLD AWAY.
>> SO, RENE, THE VISUAL HERE IS
INCREDIBLE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT 6 BILLION
TONS OF WATER MELTED EVERY DAY
OVER THOSE THREE DAYS THIS WEEK,
IT IS REALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
COMPREHEND THE STAGGERING SIZE
OF THAT.
THE QUESTION IS IS, THERE MORE
TO COME OR IS THAT THE WORST?
>> Reporter: WELL, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS PEAK MELT SEASON AND THE
ANSWER IS, YES, THERE IS MORE TO
COME.
THE NATIONAL SNOW AND ICE DATA
CENTER TELLING CNN THEY'RE
EXPECTING ANOTHER MAJOR MELT
EVENT LATER ON THIS WEEK AND
THEY ACTUALLY EXPECT THAT ONE TO
EXTEND TO MUCH MORE OF THE ICE
SHEET AND, ERIN, WE'VE SEEN IT
IN EUROPE.
MANY PARTS OF THE U.S. THERE AND
EVEN HERE